for nearly two years the rainy seasons
have failed in the lowland regions of
eastern ethiopia
the un says more than four million
people are facing critical water
shortages
in recent months the livestock they
depend on to survive have been dying in
their tens of thousands
access for journalists in ethiopia is
restricted the un released this video
from the somali region
hundreds of thousands of people are
depending on health and nutrition
support from the un's agency for
children
the un says around 200 000 children are
malnourished and the numbers are growing
fast
at mobile clinics like this one people
can get some help
[Music]
vitamin rich therapeutic feeding paste
can help to bring children back from the
brink
most of the people here depend on
herding livestock to survive they have
to walk further every month to find
water
the pools where the animals drink are a
fraction of their usual size
getting out what's left of the water
isn't easy
but it keeps thirsty camels alive the
un's mobile clinics are helping some but
it says it needs about 30 million
dollars to reach all the people who are
in need
this is part of the strategy
that we appreciate to minimize
unnecessary deaths among children and
it's a critical
integrated package of lifesaving with
sanitation promotion
treatment of acute maltreation
and the treatment of common illnesses
and including vaccinations
as more animals die and crops fail the
number of people in need just goes up
the un says in two months from now
nearly seven million people will need
help
malcolm webb al jazeera